Hi, everyone.
I'm going to talk to you
today about a book that I'm
publishing in January of 2018.
It's called 12 Rules for
Life: An Antidote to Chaos
and it's going to be published
by Penguin Random House.
I'm going to tell you how it
came about first and then I'll
describe the book's
contents and then I'm going
to read you a little bit of it.
OK.
In 2012, I did a Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation
program called Say
No to Happiness.
And in that program,
I critiqued the idea
that happiness was the proper
goal of life, claiming instead
that it's much more useful
and effective perhaps
even for producing happiness
to look for meaning
and responsibility in life.
Anyways, I received
the following email
as a consequence.
Dear Dr. Petersen, your
comments on the CBC program Say
No to Happiness were both
thought-provoking and
challenging.
They had me asking
bigger questions
and that is always
tremendously appealing.
To be perfectly
honest, some aspects
were harder for me to
understand than others,
but I was left
wanting to know more.
Have you considered writing
a book for a general,
rather than academic, reader?
I'm a literary agent and
co-owner at the Cook Agency.
We have experience
with academics
interested in writing
for a broad audience,
working with them to remove the
scaffolding that is required
in academic writing
and helping to make
their work more accessible.
We specialize in selling
authors to international markets
and developing their
writing careers.
You can find out more about
us at www.cookagency.ca.
I look forward to
hearing from you.
Sally Harding.
So a literary agent
represents an author
and attempts to
market their books.
And so they can be
extraordinarily useful people.
And in return for that,
they get a percentage
of the book's profits and that's
how they make their living.
So it's a difficult
job, especially now
because the market for
books is very complicated
and increasingly
restrictive, I would say,
to a few extremely
successful authors.
Anyways, Sally got a hold of me
and I'd thought for a long time
about writing a more popular
version of my first book called
Maps of Meaning.
And I actually produced
almost a complete manuscript
that was let's call it a
simplified version or--
I wouldn't say simplified
exactly, more--
well, I tried to make
it more accessible.
But I was never
really happy with it.
I never really felt that it
got its legs underneath it,
I suppose.
And maybe that's because I
was duplicating something
that I'd already done.
I was thinking very hard
about what to do about this
and how I might approach it
because Sally was interested
and I thought it
might be a good thing
to try to write a book for
a more general audience.
And we talked for a while
and we discussed a few ideas.
This was back in 2012.
And I mentioned to her that
I had written something
for Quora, which is
an online website,
obviously, where
anybody can post
any question and
anyone can answer it
and then the questions
are voted on.
And Quota's quite
interesting, I would say.
And I had written a
variety of answers
because I was playing
around with it.
And some of them,
as it always is,
attracted much more
attention than others.
And somebody posted, I
think it was a young guy,
posted this question, what
are the most valuable things
everyone should know?
And so I answered it.
I listed, as it was,
42 rules to live by.
And some of them were kind
of amusing, I thought,
and some of them
were dead serious.
Anyways, it became very
popular on Quora and as of now,
it has 174,000
views and 2,500 up
votes, which makes it one of
Quota's most popular answers,
as it was soon
after I posted it.
And I thought, well, people
really liked those rules,
there was something about
them that appealed to them.
So what if I write a
book based on the rules?
And so I'll read you the rules.
OK.
Maybe you'll find
them interesting.
Tell the truth.
Do not do things that
you hate, which I think
is a variant of
telling the truth
because you have to act out the
truth, as well as telling it.
Act so that you can tell
the truth about how you act,
that's obviously related
to the first two.
Pursue what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
If you have to
choose, be the one
who does things instead of the
one who is seen to do things.
Pay attention.
Assume that the person
you are listening to
might know something
you need to know.
Listen to them hard enough so
that they will share with you.
Plan and work diligently
to maintain the romance
in your relationships.
Be careful who you
share good news with.
share bad news with.
Make at least one thing better
every single place you go.
Imagine who you
could be and then
aim single-mindedly at that.
Do not allow yourself to
become arrogant or resentful.
Try to make one room in your
house as beautiful as possible.
Compare yourself to
who you were yesterday,
not to who someone
else is today.
Work as hard as you possibly
can on at least one thing
and see what happens.
If old memories
still make you cry,
write them down
carefully and completely.
Maintain your
connections with people.
Do not carelessly denigrate
social institutions
or artistic achievement.
Treat yourself as
if you were someone
that you are
responsible for helping.
Ask someone to do you a small
favor so that he or she can ask
you to do one in the future.
Make friends with people
who want the best for you.
Do not try to rescue
someone who does not
want to be rescued and be very
careful about rescuing someone
who does.
Nothing well done
is insignificant.
Set your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world.
Dress like the person
you want to be.
Be precise in your speech.
Stand up straight with
your shoulders back.
Don't avoid
something frightening
if it stands in your
way, and don't do
unnecessarily dangerous things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Do not let your
children do anything
that makes you dislike them.
Do not transform your
wife into a maid.
Do not hide unwanted
things in the fog.
Notice that opportunity
lurks where responsibility
has been abdicated.
Read something written
by someone great.
Pet a cat when you
encounter one on the street.
Don't bother children when
they're skateboarding.
Don't let bullies
get away with it.
Write a letter to
the government if you
see something that needs
fixing and propose a solution.
Remember that what
you do not yet know
is more important than
what you already know
and be grateful in
spite of your suffering.
So those were the 40-odd rules,
and people were pretty happy
with them.
And then something odd happened.
So a friend of mine is a
novelist, Greg Hurwitz.
And Greg wrote a book
that's become very popular
called Orphan X. And
one of the characters
in that book, the female lead I
would say, an off and on again
wrote romance interest
for the main character,
posted these rules on her
fridge and so they were
peppered throughout the book.
So that was kind of an
interesting development,
I thought.
And then because they
were so popular and Quora,
I talked to Sally
about the possibility
of turning them into a book.
And so my original vision
was to write 42 short essays.
I thought that would be--
and I was going to
call the book 42,
which I thought was quite
funny because if you remember,
the answer to life, the
universe, and everything
from Douglas Adams was 42.
A computer calculated that.
So I thought it would be
amusing to write a book called
42 that contained
answers to life,
the universe, and everything.
But when I started
writing the book,
it turned out that I had more
to say about each of the rules
than I had originally
envisioned.
And so I first cut it down
to 25 and wrote some essays,
and then I cut it down to 16.
And it was still
too long, and then I
cut it down to 12,
which turned out
to be a good thing anyways
because if you write a book,
you should write way more
than you're going to publish
and then cut.
Because that way, you're
only left with what's best.
So anyways, I wrote
for about three years--
well, no, it's
more than that now.
I guess it's almost five
years because I just
finished the book in September.
So it took about four
or five years to write,
and I was writing
pretty regularly.
What I'm going to do is read
to you a little bit of it,
I think.
This is the book here.
That's a galley copy,
and a galley copy
is a preprint of
a book so that you
can get some sense of
what it looks like.
It's got some nice
illustrations in it, I think,
by this comic book author
named Ethan van Sciver.
So that's kind of a rough
one on chapter three,
"Treat Yourself Like Someone You
are Responsible for Helping."
Ethan is a comic book artist,
he's a great Illustrator.
And he put each one of my kids,
I have two kids, one of them
in each illustration
sort of contemplating
the complexities
of life, I guess
that's how you
might subscribe it.
So that's one illustration.
I'll show you another one.
So that's my son,
Julian, there looking up
at the great statue of David.
And David, of course, is
an inspirational statue.
It's a representation
of what you could be.
And that's rule
three, make friends
with people who want
the best for you.
And I think I'm going to read
some of that to you right now.
Each rule is divided
into subsections--
small subchapters, let's say--
and I'll read you one of those
so you'll get some
sense of the book.
Rule three, make
friends with people
who want the best for you.
The old hometown.
The town I grew up
in had been scraped
only 50 years earlier out of the
endless flat northern prairie.
Fairview, Alberta was
part of the frontier
and had the cowboy
bars to prove it.
The Hudson's Bay Company
department store on Main Street
still bought beaver,
wolf, and coyote furs
directly from the
local trappers.
3,000 people lived there, 400
miles away from the nearest
city.
Cable TV, video games, and
internet did not exist.
It was no easy matter to
stay innocently amused
in Fairview, particularly
during the five months of winter
when long stretches of 40 below
days and even colder nights
were the norm.
The world's a different place
when it's cold like that.
The drunks in our town
ended their sad lives early.
They passed out in snow
banks at 3:00 in the morning,
froze to death.
You don't go outside
casually when it's 40 below.
On first breath, the arid desert
air constricts your lungs.
Ice forms on your eyelashes
and they stick together.
Long hair wet from the shower
freezes solid and then stands
on end, wraith-like of its own
accord later in a warm house
when it thaws bone dry,
charged with electricity.
Children only put their tongues
on steel playground equipment
once.
Smoke from house
chimneys doesn't rise.
Defeated by the cold,
it drifts downwards
and collects like fog
on snow-covered rooftops
and yards.
Cars must be
plugged in at night,
their engines warmed
by block heaters or oil
will not flow through
them in the morning
and they won't start.
Sometimes they won't anyways.
Then you turn the
engine over pointlessly
until the starter
clatters and falls silent.
Then you remove the frozen
battery from the car,
loosening bolts with stiffening
figures in the intense cold,
and bring it into the house.
It sits there sweating
for hours until it warms
enough to hold a decent charge.
You're not going to see out of
the back window of your car,
either.
It frosts over in November
and stays that way until May.
Scraping it off just
dampens the upholstery,
then that freezes, too.
Late one night going
to visit a friend,
I sat for two hours on the
edge of the passenger's seat
in a 1970 Dodge
Challenger jammed up
against the stick shift using
a vodka-soaked rag to keep
the inside of the
front windshield
clear in front of the driver
because the car heater had
quit.
Stopping wasn't an option.
There was nowhere to stop.
And it was hell on house cats.
Felines in Fairview had
short ears and tails
because they had lost the
tips of both to frostbite.
They came to resemble
arctic foxes, which
evolved those features
to deal proactively
with the intense cold.
One day our cat got
outside and no one noticed.
We found him later,
fur frozen fast
to the cold, hard concrete,
with no lasting damage
except to his pride.
Fairview cats were also at great
risk in the winter from cars,
but not for the
reasons you think.
It wasn't automobiles
sliding on icy roads
and running them over.
Only loser cats died that way.
It was cars parked
immediately after being driven
that were dangerous.
A frigid cat might think
highly of climbing up
under such a vehicle and sitting
on its still warm engine block.
But what if the driver
decided to use the car again
before the engine cooled
down and the cat departed?
Let's just say that
heat-seeking house
pets and rapidly
rotating radiator fans
do not co-exist happily.
Because we were so far north,
the bitterly cold winters
were very dark.
By December, the sun
didn't rise until 10:00 AM.
We trudged to school
in the pitch black.
It wasn't much lighter
when we walked home just
before the early sunset.
There wasn't much
for young people
to do in Fairview,
even in the summer,
but the winters were worse.
Then your friends mattered
more than anything.
So that's a little section
of 12 Rules for Life.
I can tell you
what the rules are.
It's foreword was
written by Norman Doidge.
He comments a little bit
about the political turmoil
that surrounded me
over the last year,
although the book itself is very
apolitical with the exception
of the chapter on
skateboarding, where
I go into the ongoing,
polarizing battle between I
would say the radical
left and everyone else.
But other than that, it's
not a political book.
So the table of
contents includes
rule one, stand up straight
with your shoulders back.
That's actually a
story that centers
on lobsters to a large degree.
I have a proclivity for
talking about lobsters.
Rule two, treat yourself
like someone you
are responsible for helping.
That's something
that people don't
do very well because they're
not very happy with themselves
often.
Rule three, make
friends with people
who want the best for you.
That's the chapter
I already read.
I read the first part of it.
And it's about trying
to organize your life
so that you're
surrounded by people
who support you when you're
trying to do what's right.
It's very important.
Rule four, compare yourself
to who you were yesterday
and not to who
someone else is today.
Because if you're comparing
yourself to someone else,
I mean, first of all,
you don't know very much
about the life of the person
you are comparing yourself to;
you don't know it across
all of its dimensions.
And second, people
are very different
and so comparing
yourself to someone else
is kind of useful, I
guess, when you're young.
But as you get older and more
singular and more particular,
it becomes increasingly
less useful.
Better to compare yourself to
a previous version of yourself
and work for
improvement in that way.
Rule five, do not
let your children
do anything that makes
you dislike them.
That's probably going to be
the most controversial chapter,
I would say.
It's a chapter about discipline
and love and respect.
I guess that's probably right.
Rule six, set your
house in perfect order
before you criticize the world.
Yeah.
Well, that's a
rough chapter, man.
I'm trying to
explain the mindset
behind people like the
Columbine High School shooters.
And so it's a harsh chapter.
Rule seven, pursue
what is meaningful
and not what is expedient.
Expedient is what works
in the short term,
expedient is what's easy.
Meaningful, instead, is what
sustains you through tragedy,
let's say.
Rule eight, tell the truth,
or at least don't lie.
Yeah.
Well, it's not that easy to
tell the truth because who
knows about the truth?
But you can learn
not to say things
that you know to be false.
And if you stop saying things
that you know to be false,
then your life
will improve a lot.
It simplifies it and it puts
you in alignment with reality.
And you should be in
alignment with reality
because there's a lot more
of it than there is of you.
Rule nine, assume that the
person you're listening
to might know
something you don't.
That's a good one because--
and this is even true when
you're dealing with people that
don't like you because they may
offer you criticisms
that are valid--
many that aren't, too, of course
because maybe they're just
trying to take you down a bit.
But if you get a
criticism that's valid
and then you can fix
that error, let's say,
that'll stop you from running
nose first into walls,
and that's generally
a handy thing.
Rule 10, be precise
in your speech.
Yeah.
Well, you have to be
exacting in the way
that you subscribe
things and the way
that you think because
otherwise, you live in the fog
and you won't get what
you should out of life
or what you need out of life.
And by need, I mean what will
sustain you so that you don't
become bitter and resentful.
Rule 11, do not bother children
when they're skateboarding.
So that chapter is about I would
say our society's hyper concern
with safety and its
fundamental antagonism
to exploratory behavior,
especially among boys.
Rule 12, pet a cat when you
encounter one on the street.
Yeah.
Well, that's about trying to
orient yourself towards life so
that even when you're in
the middle of a crisis
or a tragedy, you can find bits
and pieces of experience that
are positive and sustaining so
that you can stay positively
oriented towards your own
existence and towards existence
itself.
So anyways, that's the book.
And it's coming
out January 23rd,
although it's
available for preorder
at Amazon.com or Amazon.ca
and several other places.
I'll put links in the
video description.
If you're trying to figure
out how to orient yourself
in the midst of the chaos
that constitutes life,
then you might find some of the
things that I wrote in 12 Rules
for Life Helpful.
So I hope that that was
interesting and goodbye
for now.